[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola buenas tardes de todos
este año hemos vivido de un día para
otro todo cambió como vivimos como
trabajamos y hasta como nos divertimos y
aprovechando el miedo y la incertidumbre
de esta situación los ciberdelincuentes
son muy pero muy activos 53 68 91 que
quieren decir estos números el 53 por
ciento de los ataques simplemente no
están detectados mientras que 68% de rne
se mueve pasan desapercibidos
y finalmente 91% de los ataques no están
generando alertas en los sistemas como
siempre
como es posible que nuestra industria de
ciberseguridad hemos llegado a este
estándar es pésimo y no es excepto
seguramente ustedes habrán escuchado
estéticas similares a estas y sólo
destaca la ineficacia de las estrategias
y esquemas de ciberseguridad hoy en día
y los números solamente van a empeorar
de hecho según un artículo de cnpc
recientemente en lo que vamos en la
pandemia las brechas han aumentado un
273% mientras que los ataques de
ransomware han crecido 90% y finalmente
los ataques más maliciosos los que
destruyen los datos y las redes han
aumentado 102 por ciento y porque bueno
una de las principales razones es que
millones de personas siguen trabajando
desde su casa
y para facilitar este cambio drástico
los ciber profesionales han tenido que
enfocarse en las tareas básicas de ti
como evento esto representa un gran
desafío para las organizaciones al
transformar sus flujos y procesos a un
entorno digital de un día al otro en
tiempo real y mientras tanto encontrar
la forma de protegerlo es casi imposible
ahora nuestro equipo de inteligencia nos
informa que las tácticas técnicas y
procedimientos de los atacantes
realmente no ha cambiado drásticamente
pero nuestra realidad si ha cambiado lo
que representa un riesgo mayor para las
organizaciones recuerden ese 53 68 91
eso fue antes de la pandemia entonces
qué vamos a hacer
obviamente el modelo tradicional e
invertir mucho y luego asumir que las
soluciones estén bien implementados
configurados y administrados ya es
obsoleto hay que cambiar el paradigma
y cómo
la respuesta es a través de la
validación continua que permite
identificar cuáles controles de
seguridad están funcionando como
deberían o no
y entonces la pregunta para las empresas
es dónde comenzar y cómo priorizar esa
validación y para mí la respuesta es
sencilla la validación debe realizarse
de una forma automática y continua y más
importante basado en los comportamientos
de ataques reales o en otras palabras
las balas reales y no en simulaciones
la realidad es que sin datos veraces
como estas que demuestran la efectividad
los pisos están operando baja bajo de
supuestos y eso es peligroso
s 53 68 91 demuestra ese peligro
en mis varias conversaciones con los
hijos en la región el desafío en común
cada uno tiene es la presión de seguir
mejorando su protección mientras que
encuentran la forma de optimizar los
recursos financieros realmente es una
pesadilla para estos ejecutivos y es
peor aún en esta pandemia cuando no
saben qué va a pasar en el futuro
inmediato si la fuerza va a volver a
trabajar o si vuelvan la oficina y de
repente hay un aumento de casos y tiene
que volver a la casa hay varios
escenarios
y por ende la importancia de la
validación el punto es sin datos reales
no van a poder tomar decisiones
correctas con anticipación van a tener
que asumir
trasladando este concepto a los tiempos
de la pandemia
pensamos en un hospital y la importancia
de validar todos sus controles procesos
y protocolos y especialmente en esta
época de kobe un hospital puede tener
todos los respiradores medicamentos
camas instrumentos y todos los médicos
entrenados del mundo pero si están
operando bajo el supuesto que el
paciente tiene cover pero en realidad
tiene otra enfermedad eso puede podría
poner en riesgo la vida del paciente
entonces si el diagnóstico no es preciso
están operando sobre supuestos y eso
obviamente puede poner en riesgo la vida
del paciente
entonces como pueden ver ya no es
suficiente contar con la mejor
tecnología ni el capital humano porque
todo tiene que funcionar correctamente
para cada situación o cada caso
un buen ejemplo de esto es al principio
del año que se siente como hace diez
años para mí y el ataque contra el
general so alemania irán inmediatamente
y declaró una retaliación cibernética
contra las empresas de eeuu entonces
pensamos en los dos escenarios los
clientes con validación y los clientes
sin validación los clientes sin
validación tenía que asumir que todas
las tecnologías todos los esquemas y
posturas de seguridad ya era suficiente
para parar estos ataques al cambio los
clientes con validación tenían el lujo
a adoptar y usar las mismas tácticas
técnicas y procedimientos de estos
grupos y de ahí estar seguro que sus
esquemas y postura y tecnología era
suficiente para detectar y parar estos
ataques y estar seguro que su postura
esquemas y controles eran suficiente
para reconocer y para los ataques de
estos grupos la diferencia es bien clara
al asumir y esperar que todo va a
resultar bien y validar y estar 100%
seguro obviamente estamos pasando por un
momento único que ha obligado a las
organizaciones a celebrar la adopción de
las estrategias y esquemas de seguridad
que ya tenían planificado para el largo
plazo pero hay algo bueno de eso ahora
tiene la oportunidad de implementar una
visión que provea la capacidad de
entregar todas las tecnologías actuales
igualmente las que van a comprar en el
futuro con la inteligencia de amenazas
reales
y todo apoyado en las experiencias
reales de los profesionales en la línea
frente 53 68 91 los números no mienten y
el hecho es que sin evidencias del
desempeño en tiempo real van a seguir
operando sobre estos mismos supuestos
que no concuerdan con la realidad y lo
que representa un riesgo significativo
por lo tanto la mejor manera de combatir
ese desconexión es validar la eficacia
del programa en una forma autorizada y
continua y hasta que logren esta nueva
normalidad no van a tener la confianza
completa de que sus estrategias y de
esquemas realmente están logrando el
gran objetivo de proteger los activos
críticos la marca obviamente los
ejecutivos la reputación general de la
compañía y todos los aspectos
financieros
muchas gracias por su atención
[Aplausos]
[Música]